REACTION TO THAT BREAKING NEWS
LATER BUT FIRST
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" PUBLISHED
TRUMPS TAXES FROM 30 YEARS AGO.
YOU MIGHT ASK HOW DID THEY GET
THE STUFF BUT THAT DOESN'T
MATTER IF YOU HATE THE GUY.
PUBLISHING OTHER PEOPLE STUFF IS
WHAT THE TIMES IS ALL ABOUT.
WHO CARES IF IT WAS LEAKED OR
STOLEN.
OR MAY BE BORROWED FROM TRUMP.
>> IT WASN'T ALWAYS SO EASY.
ABOUT 13 YEARS AGO, I WAS
SERIOUSLY IN TROUBLE.
I WAS MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN
DEBT.
>> Greg: THAT'S WHAT THE TIMES
REPORTED LAST NIGHT, QUITE A
BOMBSHELL.
ALSO THE TIMES LAST NIGHT, THE
BERLIN WALL, DOWN.
THE BAY CITY ROLLERS BROKE UP.
NOBODY KNOWS THEM.
"STAR WARS," ACTUALLY A HIT.
AND TRUMP ONCE LOST A BUNDLE,
SAY INSIDERS, INCLUDING TRUMP
HIMSELF.
HERE'S AN IDEA.
GET THE RICH KID WHO OWNS THE
TIMES TO TURN OVER HIS 1040s.
IF THE TIMES GETS ANOTHER
ELIXIR, THEY SHOULD SHARE IT
WITH TRUMP FOR TIPPING THEM OFF
YEARS AGO.
STILL, THE MEDIA, THEIR
RESPONSES PAVLOVIAN.
>> DONALD TRUMP IS OUR CON MAN
IN CHIEF.
>> WHATEVER THE OPPOSITE OF
EVERYTHING YOU TOUCH TURNING TO
GOLD, THAT'S THE OPPOSITE OF
WHAT DONALD TRUMP HAD.
>> YOU HAVE A WORD FOR SOMEONE
WHO CAN BUILD UP AN IMAGE LIKE
THAT DESPITE THE FACTS, CORRECT?
>> CON ARTIST.
>> NO ONE HAS LOST AS MUCH
MONEY.
>> Greg: MAY BE IN A DIVORCE.
ANYWAY, HERE IS THE MEDIA'S
IMMORTAL TAKE.
WE GOT HIM AGAIN.
THIS TIME, RIGHT, WE GOT HIM,
RIGHT?
NO, BUT IT'S FUN TO WATCH YOU
TRY.
IT'S HILARIOUS.
THEY KEEP STEPPING ON THE SAME
RAKE AND GETTING WHACKED IN THE
HEAD AGAIN AND AGAIN.
THE ANTI-TRUMP HEADLINES KEEP
FALLING FLAT.
LIFE IS GOOD AND THE ECONOMY IS
ROARING.
ON EMPLOYMENT KEEPS HITTING
RECORD LOW SO WHEN YOU'RE IN THE
MEDIA ON THE WORLD DOESN'T GO
YOUR WAY OF GOT TO FIND ANOTHER
STORY.
EVEN IF THE STORIES BEEN TOLD
OVER AND OVER AGAIN BY THE
TARGET HIMSELF.
I CAN'T WAIT TO HEAR ABOUT THE
NEXT SCOOP THAT TRUMP HAS BEEN
MARRIED TWICE, THAN HE LOVES
GOLF, AND WOMEN, AND YES, WHAT
DO YOU HAVE FROM THE AMERICAN
PUBLIC?
THE SOUND OF LIFE IN 2019 AND
UNDER TRUMP.
THE SOUND OF CALM.
AS THE PRESS SHOULD KNOW BY NOW,
YOU CAN'T HEAR IT WHEN YOU'RE
SCREAMING.
ALL RIGHT, DANA, I WANT TO SHOW
YOU HOW OLD THIS NEWS IS.
WE HAVE SOME PICTURES OF SOME
OLD TABLOID COVERS.
HIS FINANCIAL ALES.
TRUMP SLUMP, ABOUT HIS FINANCIAL
ALES.
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" ONE, IT'S
ABOUT HIS FINANCIAL ALES -- AIL
AILS.
DANA, YOU ARE ABOUT 3 YEARS OLD.
>> Dana: HAVING TO GO THROUGH
THE NEW YORK MEDIA GAUNTLET.
I DIDN'T APPRECIATE THAT UNTIL I
HAD BEEN IN POLITICS MYSELF, AT
THE WHITE HOUSE OR EVEN HERE.
>> Greg: YOU WORKED FOR TRUMP.
I MEAN YOU WORKED FOR BUSH.
>> Dana: IT CAN SHAPE A WHOLE
GENERATION.
EVERYONE HERE KNOWS
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
THEY'VE KNOWN FOR 30 YEARS.
YOU TALK ABOUT INSIDER, HE'S THE
ULTIMATE INSIDER.
THERE'S NOTHING YOU DON'T KNOW.
>> Greg: IT'S TRUE.
IF I REMEMBER, HE TALKED ABOUT
THIS AND ABOUT HOW THE TAX THING
IS A GAME.
I KNOW.
>> Jesse: I LOVE IT WHEN YOU
DO FOX NEWS BREAKING NEWS
ALERTS.
CAN YOU ALWAYS DO THAT?
THERE IS SOMETHING VERY GUTFELD
GUTFELD-IAN ABOUT IT.
HE WROTE A BOOK, THE ART OF THE
COMEBACK AND HE EXPLAINED
EVERYTHING ABOUT THE TAX LOSSES.
YOU TAKE A LOSS WHEN YOU BUILD A
BUSINESS.
I THINK ALSO IN THE '80s,
WASN'T HE ON A MASSIVE,
MULTIMILLION DOLLAR BUYING
SPREE.
HE BOUGHT THE PLAZA HOTEL FOR
HALF A BILLION.
HE BOUGHT A YACHT, FOOTBALL
FRANCHISE, AN AIRLINE.
WHEN YOU GROW BUSINESS, YOU'RE
GOING TO HAVE SOME LIABILITIES
AND THEN YOU CAN WRITE OFF WITH
THE DEPRECIATION.
THE POINT IS, AFTER HE DID THIS
AND TOOK THE LOSSES,
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" CALLED HIM
THE COMEBACK KING.
SPEAKING OF THE MARITIMES,
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" LOST A
BILLION DOLLARS BUYING
"THE BOSTON GLOBE" AND THEY HAVE
HAD TO GET BAILED OUT BY MEXICAN
BILLIONAIRE CARLOS SLIM, THEY
STILL OPERATE TO THIS DAY ON A
QUARTER BILLION DOLLARS IN
LOSSES.
ALSO EVERYBODY LOSES MONEY WHEN
THEY'RE BUILDING A BUSINESS.
TWITTER LOST $2 BILLION SINCE IT
WENT PUBLIC.
LUBER LAST YEAR ALONE LOST
$3 BILLION AND LET'S LOOK AT THE
POLITICIANS, AOC LOST THE STATE,
$24 BILLION IN REVENUE PER
BARACK OBAMA DOUBLED OUR DEBT.
LOST TO HAVE A BILLION TO
SOLYNDRA.
LOST 2 BILLION ON A BROKEN
WEBSITE.
HILLARY LOST A BILLION HER DONOR
SHELLED OUT WHEN SHE LOST HER
DONALD TRUMP.
HE MAY HAVE LOST A LOT OF MONEY
BUT NOW HE HAS TOWERS ALL OVER
THE GOLD.
HE'S GOT GREAT GOLF COURSES, AND
HE IS THE PRESIDENCY.
IT'S PRETTY GOOD.
>> Greg: WHAT DO YOU THINK,
JUAN?
>> Juan: I THINK HE HAD HIS
DADDY TO BAIL HIM OUT.
GIVE HIM 400-PLUS MILLION TO
HELP THEM OUT.
>> Greg: IS IN
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" A FAMILY
BUSINESS?
>> Juan: WHAT I'M STRUCK BY IS
TRUMP LIES TO HIS SUPPORTERS.
HE SAYS I AM A SUCCESSFUL
BUSINESSMAN.
THAT'S WACK AND RUN THIS COUNTRY
THAT ARE THAN ANYONE ELSE.
I'LL MAKE YOU RICH BECAUSE I'M
RICH.
THEN IT TURNS OUT IT'S A SCAM.
HE LOST MORE MONEY THAN ANYBODY
ELSE IN AMERICA APPARENTLY.
>> Greg: IS ALSO MADE MORE
MONEY.
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENS.
IT GOES UP AND DOWN.
ECONOMIC MOBILITY.
>> Juan: OR JESSE GOES ON
ABOUT SOMEONE ELSE LOST MONEY.
THIS GUY LOST MONEY.
PLEASE.
LET'S PAY ATTENTION THE FACT OF
THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES MAY IN FACT HAVE
ENGAGED IN TAX FRAUD, BANK
FRAUD.
THESE ARE SERIOUS
CONSIDERATIONS.
>> Greg: SERIOUS ACCUSATIONS.
>> Juan: THAT'S WHY THE
CONGRESS SHOULD HAVE ACCESS TO
HIS TAX RECORDS.
IF HE'S LOSING ALL THIS MONEY IN
RUSSIA OR SOME OTHER COUNTRY
DECIDES WE CAN GET OUR HOOKS
INTO THE SKY THAT BAIL HIM OUT,
WE THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> Greg: THE RUSSIANS.
IT'S THE RUSSIANS, JEDEDIAH BILA
THEY'RE GOING TO COLLUDE NOW
WITH HIS BUSINESSES.
>> Jedediah: YOU TALKED ABOUT
HIM TALKING ABOUT BEING A
BUSINESSMAN AND OH, HE'S A GREAT
BUSINESSMAN AND NOW IT'S HIS
SELLING POINT.
WHAT'S THE STORY?
LET'S SAY HE WAS A TERRIBLE
BUSINESSMAN.
HE'S NOT BECAUSE THE BUSINESSES
WOUND UP BLOOMING BUT EVEN IF
YOU SAY THAT, THAT CANNOT
TRANSLATE TO A POOR ECONOMY.
YOU CANNOT CHANGE THE REALITY
THAT THIS GUY WHO WENT IN THERE,
HAD EXPERIENCE WITH BUSINESS,
SUFFERED SOME LOSSES, CAME OUT
OF IT, STILL MANAGED TO GET A
BOOMING ECONOMY WITH HIS
POLICIES OF DEREGULATION,
LOWERING TAXES AND WHATNOT.
YOU CAN'T TAKE THAT AWAY FROM
HIM.
BUSINESS OWNERS AROUND THE
COUNTRY READ A STORY LIKE THIS.
I COME FROM A FAMILY WHERE MY
MOM AND DAD RAN A SMALL
BUSINESS.
IT'S REALLY HARD.
THEY SAW THIS AND THEY SOUGHT
RELATABILITY.
THEY SAID GUESS WHAT.
YOU OPEN THE BUSINESS, SMALL OR
LARGE COMING STRUGGLE.
YOU FALL.
SOMETIMES YOU'RE LUCKY ENOUGH TO
BE ABLE TO BUILD YOURSELF BACK
UP AGAIN, AND HE WAS HONEST
ABOUT THIS.
HE SAID IF WE JUST PLAY THE
TAPE.
PEOPLE AT HOME OR SAYING I'M
SORRY BUT WHAT IS THE STORY
HERE?
A COMEBACK STORY?
>> Juan: IT'S NOT LIKE YOUR
FOLKS BECAUSE THIS RICH KID HAD
A BIG DADDY TO COME IN AND BAIL
HIM OUT.
INSTEAD OF SAYING I STRUGGLE
LIKE EVERYBODY.
HE LIED ABOUT IT.
HERE'S THE FINAL POINT I WANT TO
MAKE, GREG.
>> Greg: OKAY.
>> Juan: YOU TALK ABOUT
SOCIALISM.
THIS IS SOCIALISM FOR THE RICH.
THE WORKING MAN IN AMERICA PAYS
TAXES AND HE, FOR TEN YEARS,
DONALD TRUMP PAID NO TAXES AND
WE BAILED HIM OUT.
>> Jesse: YOU JUST SAID HE WAS
BROKE.
HE SAID HE WASN'T RICH.
HE'S GOT A JET.
HE'S GOT MAR-A-LAGO,
TRUMP TOWER, IT'S PRETTY GOOD.
>> Jedediah: THAT DOESN'T
CHANGE THE SUCCESS HE'S HAD WITH
THE ECONOMY AND VOTERS ARE NOT
VOTING BASED ON DONALD TRUMP'S
RECORD FROM 35 YEARS AGO WITH
HIS PRIVATE BUSINESS.
THEY ARE VOTING ON HOW MUCH
MONEY THEY HAVE IN THEIR POCKET
AND WHAT LIFE LOOKS LIKE FOR
THEM SINCE HE'S ELECTED.
>> Juan: THE TRUMP CULT.
>> Greg: THEY ELECTED HIM OVER
THE DEMOCRAT.
QUITE A CULT.
60 SOME-ODD MILLION.